[Music]
so the first one was the question if
human-level AI is developed then what
are the likely outcomes and I'm going to
try to go over this fairly quickly to
spend more time on the second question
but we heard about them is talking about
the alphago project earlier and I think
that can be used to illustrate one
possible scenario here so I want to zoom
in on one specific aspect of this which
is the timeline so we had the the first
game with the European champion in
October 2015 and at least at all at that
point said based on its level of play
that I saw in in this initial practice
match I think I will win the game by a
near landslide so Lisa doll is very
optimistic in October of 2015 then we
have February 2016
oops this so he becomes a little bit a
little bit disconcerted here I've heard
that google's deepmind is surprisingly
strong and getting stronger but I'm
confident that I can win at least this
time then a little bit later in mark
March 9th this is after the first the
first game of the best-of-five I was
very surprised because I didn't think I
would lose then the following day after
the second game is now even more sorry I
was quite speechless he says that he
admits that the third game is not going
to be easy
finally he admits that and then let's
see I should have practiced from this
it's it soon gonna be over March 12th I
felt kind of powerless so the
interesting thing here is I mean
obviously there's all the interesting
engineering and the creative
problem-solving that winds into
achieving this but also notice the
timescale here so it's about half a year
from being confident that it just can't
compete with the best humans to being
completely overwhelmed and as we heard
alphago has continued to improve at the
rapid keep since then so my answer to
the question of what happens if like I
wonder what will go wrong next if human
level a is developed then what are the
likely outcomes I think is super
intelligence and possibly within a
relatively short time frame now you can
then ask what are the likely outcomes of
super intelligence and I'm not going to
go into this I'm going to refer you to
do it in my book which talks a lot about
this and
I'm but I think there's a range of
outcomes and I actually I spent a lot of
time in them sorry I'm I feel partly
responsible here's I spent a lot of time
in the book talking about what could go
wrong because it seemed to me when I was
writing the book especially a few years
ago that let's thank you well place that
there it seemed it seemed more important
at that point to to develop more
fine-grained understanding of what could
possibly go wrong so we could make sure
we know where the pitfalls are and we
can avoid them whereas it seemed we
could get by with a fairly vague general
sense of the enormous upside but I think
that maybe some people reading the book
mistook the number of pages allocated to
different topics for the probability
estimate of that actually coming to pass
I would say that I'm actually more
positive about AI and its potential then
then some people might have come away
believing so now to the second question
which I want to sort of spend the rest
of the time on what can we do now to
maximize the probability of a good
outcome so there are basically three
things we need we need to solve
intelligence like to get the good
outcome of super intelligence we need to
create super intolerance so that
involves a lot of difficult technical
challenges then we'll need to figure out
how to solve the technical control
problem and and the governor's problem
so I'm just going to note with regard to
solving intelligence that it's a very
difficult problem but there is also a
lot of progress being made and huge
resources being poured into this and
it's a really exciting time in this
field but the latest nipson in barcelona
I think had like 6500 people attending
which is up something like 40 percent
from the year before which is in turn up
from the air before and there is it's
just a giant magnet right now for
talented people coming of age in
computer science or neighboring fields
so that will require a lot of work but I
feel too
some extent we've got it covered it's
like good progress there we are
basically doing what needs to be done in
order to make progress in AI the world
is having its act together in that
respect now on the second problem
solving scalable control developing
control methods that can ensure that
even if we develop arbitrarily powerful
AI systems in the future that they will
still be safe still be aligned with
human values we are much farther behind
but we are a lot further ahead than we
were when this group met two years ago
in Puerto Rico there has been actually a
quite remarkable change in the landscape
what we have for example now is various
technical research agendas so we've
moved from just having the sense of
really powerful AI maybe it could be
dangerous we need to figure out how to
control it to having now a set of topics
that you could imagine assigning a PhD
student to work on this and they would
be able to figure out how to produce
some technical papers and begin to make
incremental progress on this so this is
a big step forward we also have some
work starting to come out from this and
we have the beginnings of a research
community it's still very small but but
there are now several different research
groups that are working on this doing
technical work gradually refining that
and testing it and so I want to I want
to give a shout out at this point to
some of the people who have helped
enable this by providing funding Elon
Musk also for the future of humanity
Institute Alexander Thomas and John
Talon thank you very much this is like
super gay
a third thing that has happened on the
technical front is the growing
acceptability of this and the
collaborations that have started
springing up so it's not now just a
separate little community of a few
outsiders who think we should do work on
this but deepmind has been a pioneer in
taking the technical control problem
seriously joined more recently with by
open AI which is also starting to
produce work in this and technical
research agendas and and coordinating a
collaborating we have regular research
seminars with deep lines and so forth
and I think that that's very very
healthy these these communities really
need to fuse and that's beginning to
happen that's really exciting so that
leaves us with the third problem that we
need to solve the AI governance problem
broadly construed so this is a big
complex topic and I want to just pick
out one strand one one thought within
that to discuss with you today which is
a slightly difficult and problematic
aspect I want to talk about openness in
AI development and how we should think
about that so we've got a number of
papers recently that that addresses
various aspects of this some is my own
work some is with colleagues Alan that's
our character in Stuart Armstrong Carl
Shulman who are here in the audience and
I'm just going to be able to scratch the
surface but as a first step to think
about this we want to distinguish
different things you could be open about
in terms of advances in the technical
control problem you could be open about
your thinking about that and that that
seems clearly good like if you develop a
way to keep AI safe you want to share it
with everybody else so that their areas
can also be safe values in terms of what
what the goal ultimately also and
objectives are of your organization it
seems positive for there to be openness
about that because it would tend to
differentially benefit organizations
that have beneficial goals that other
people
prove off the more you can see what
different groups are ultimately trying
to achieve them the more people can
support the ones that are trying to
achieve something good so I'll put the
green checkmark on that - I'm not going
to talk much about capability heads
complex is showing its own but I want to
I want to talk about openness with
regard to the science with regard to the
source code the platform's training data
environments things that directly help
push the technical capabilities forward
because here I think that the picture is
a little bit more complex as to the
desirability of this over different time
scales I want to make this observation
which is that to the extent that there
is openness in the development that
would in expectation reduce the gap
between the leading developer and the
nearest following developer day there
are various factors that could create
dispersion among different development
teams that might have access to
different amounts of hardware that might
have access to a different amount of
data but that might also have different
algorithms because they have found
different ideas so if you equalize one
of those that will tend to reduce the
spread so that perhaps while you might
imagine in in a low openness scenario
that that the leader might be a few
years ahead of the nearest follower in a
high openness scenario where they can
always see exactly each other's most
recent algorithmic advances and
scientific ideas that this person would
shrink perhaps instead that would be a
few months and you could imagine in the
limiting case whatever what I had
exactly the same source code there would
be no dispersion from from from
differences in that and it would just be
a matter of who has the most hardware
let's say our data so so that that is
one property of openness that I think is
significant now this has some positive
consequences for a start it probably
helps advance the field more rapidly in
the near term science advanced is best
when
results are shared and so that people
can build on them thinking about the
long-term outcomes it also has the
potentially beneficial
result of reducing the risk that one
small group monopolizes all the benefit
kind of spreads the capability more
around makes it harder for any one group
to kind of achieve as monopoly situation
however there are some important
qualifications here or concerns
potential downsides to openness so
suppose it turns out that safety solving
the control problem requires some
significant amount of extra work after
the AI is basically completed like maybe
there is some kind of safety module that
you can only install after the other
modules are in place or maybe you have
all of the safety thing installed but
you want some period of time when you
can test it in a controlled environment
without sort of pouring on the gasoline
and allowing it to reach its full
potential maybe you would really like to
have four months after you basically
have your system finished before you
kind of bring it up to superintelligence
or release it into the natural
environment now in a maximally open
scenario where you basically have an
inability for the lead developer to have
any significant advantage over the
nearest followers it seems impossible in
this scenario for that extra safety work
to be done maybe the lead developer is
responsible and decides to pause but
that just means somebody else
Sushi's right by so it looks in this
scenario that that extra safety required
to make extra safety work requires to
make the AI safe will just not happen in
the limit in case we have a large number
of competitors that are within days of
one another so in an unfavorable snorer
if the world is such that you require
this extra safety word that can only be
done at the end maximum openness
[Music]
bracketing the question of compute power
it seems to lead to a catastrophic
outcome or here's an alternative
supposition suppose that safe operation
of the AI initially require requires
accepting some performance penalty like
maybe the initial safety techniques are
not that great it requires
maybe a human supervisor to inspect
every minute exactly what the ice plans
are and approving them and you go slowly
or there are other things that that cost
increase the computational cost by 10x
or something like that then again if you
have a world where a lot of different
developers independently have the
capability of deciding to down-regulate
their safety investment the lead will
then go to however cuts to most corners
and invests least in safety and they
will zoom ahead and potentially be able
to shape the future with their unsafe AI
so again you have a very bad outcome a
third so these are discounted
possibilities it surprises if one of
these is true the third is if what I
call it the vulnerable world hypothesis
happens to be true in the post a I
transition what's the vulnerable world
hypothesis they thought is this the
hypothesis is that there is some level
of technology at which Athens strongly
dominates defense in the sense that any
small group with reasonable competent
people with access to that hypothetical
technology would be able to talk some
action that would lead to the
destruction of the world independently
of what other people do after that
action is taken so we don't know whether
the vulnerable world hypothesis is true
but there might be a lot of technologies
above the ones we have currently
developed and if at one level of
technology it turns out that this this
property holds that oftens is just it's
not just a lot easier to destroy them to
defend with at that level of technology
then there is this world vulnerability
that human civilization will encounter
once we reach that level of
technological development you could
imagine different possible you know
maybe maybe in biotech at some
particular level of advancement it turns
out to be easier to concoct some some
doomsday agent than to create the the
therapeutic or the vaccine or nanotech
or maybe some as yet unconceived
technology might have this unfortunate
property like we were lucky with nuclear
weapons that they are really hard to
build if if you could have unleashed the
power of the atom by some easy method
like baking sand in the microwave
and then maybe human civilization would
have ended in 1946 we were fortunate at
that time but you know you keep
inventing these new thinks maybe the
next nuclear weapon will not require
plutonium or highly enriched uranium but
some some easy thing so again if it
should turn out that this vulnerable
world hypothesis is true particularly in
such a way that with advanced AI you are
able to reach this technology that
enables the extremely destructive
morality then again it seems problematic
if there are many independent actors
that have access to that technology so
[Music]
while openness on safety measures values
seem really positive openness with
regard to these technical ingredients is
more problematic what should we do in
light of this well so I think that for
now
openness makes a lot of sense we are not
yet at the level of AI were where these
concerns would really kick in so we can
continue to do the academic frolicking
and exploration and curiosity and like
moving things forward in an open manner
but when thinking about past forward
trajectories future governance
institutions this looks like a very
desirable property a conditional
stabilization that is if it at some
point starts to look as if the world is
vulnerable in one of these senses or as
if solving the scalable control problem
requires doing extra work after the AI
is finished or as if we'd initially
developed control methods there will be
a performance penalty if it turns out
that the world is like that then we want
to be in a position where we can
stabilize this competitive race and
avoid the race dynamic like we want to
have that option in the world because it
looks like a real possibility that the
world could be like that so hmm
that suggests that what we might want to
do now even as we continue open
scientific development is to try to lay
the foundations
for a collaborative approach later which
would involve perhaps coordination
between their leading AI research groups
at some future point where it started to
look like the potentially concerning
forms of AI were getting close at that
point rather than each of them racing to
the finish line it would be much better
if they could coordinate form some joint
venture cross invest may be ideally pull
the resources and go forward together so
that they extend their lead over the non
included laggards a little bit extra
lead time and then don't race against
one another that means perhaps that we
should now be working to create the
ability not to share science and
algorithms until it is safe to do so so
we can continue to share them but we
want to sort of build up the capability
of making a different choice later which
might mean for example when you're
recruiting new scientists into your
organization saying that yes you're
perfectly happy free to publish as you
see fit but if there might come a future
time when we might have to stop the free
publication because sort of starts to
make that possible and working on other
things in the organizations like
cybersecurity so that your algorithmic
advances can't just be stolen at a later
time if it turns out that that stopping
openness becomes important and also to
try to develop ways to credibly commit
to sharing the benefits and the
influence the one thing that reduces the
temptation to race is if you could be
confident that if somebody else wins the
race it's still going to be good for you
so it's not a win or or die situation
but that it's good whoever wins that
would also reduce the intensity of the
racing dynamic so that you could get
some of the benefits of the open
development which is that we all get to
share in the outcomes it's not going to
be monopolized or captured by a small
clique but without the downsides which
is the sort of blind race towards the
precipice thank you very much
[Music]